hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of Science
and Technology
so I noticed a number of questions which
are accumulated here let me see what I
can do to address them
so I see asks the question what would
you say is the most important human
decide that designed algorithm of all
time
interesting question
you know I think uh I was curious at one
point what is the most used human
designed algorithm ever and I think the
answer is the algorithm that generates
the linear feedback shift register
sequences designed by a person I knew
named solgalom
um that's a
what that's used for is when you have
you're trying to generate a sequence of
bits
that you don't want to repeat and you
don't want sub blocks of that sequence
of repeat of bits to repeat
uh you you want it to go for as long as
possible without repeating and you want
the sub blocks to not repeat for as long
as possible
and so what that has the effect of is if
you take the sequence and you try and
say you take one version of the sequence
you take another version of the sequence
they are maximally unlikely to be
correlated with each other
and where's that useful well it's useful
in many places so for example CDMA
telephony for cell phones uh what tends
to be done is that you each Channel
the for the cell phone is encoded with a
different linear feedback shift Road or
shifted linear feedback shift strategy
sequence and because these things are
maximally don't overlap they have the
best chance to kind of use the same
radio frequencies while not interfering
with each other
and it's also used in GPS
it's the sequences that get generated
that um
give you uh the the maximal related GPS
receiver know
what time is it based on the GPS
satellite where because you you you find
out where in the sequence are you the
sequence only repeats let's say every
few days and it's running at a very uh
High rate and you're asking where in the
sequence are we oh we're at day three
hours such and such second such and such
milliseconds such and such and you can
tell that because the sequence has these
blocks that are sort of maximally
non-repetitive also turns out to be used
in all kinds of unexpected places like
what's used in Wi-Fi it's used and for
the same reason it's used in cell phones
it's used even when you send data from a
computer to the display uh to the
computer display it's used there because
it's convenient in the electronics to
never have something which consistently
has zero voltage you always want the
thing to be sort of wiggling around and
this is a convenient way to have it
wiggle around and it'd be easy to decode
so I I think I worked out how many times
in history that algorithm has been used
the algorithm that generates uh these
linear feedback shift Traders sequences
a very simple algorithm a shift register
is just something where you have a
collection of bits and at every step
you're shifting one bit off the end and
you're having it come back to the
beginning again that's a feedback shift
register a feedback shift registers were
first set up in the 1940s
um initially with uh sometimes for
electronics
um sometimes even they were part of
things like delay lines like one of the
early types of memories was a Mercury
delay line memory but you would have
these ultrasound pulses that would
propagate through the Mercury come to
the other end then be Amplified then be
sent back again that was kind of the
minimal uh sort of feedback shift
register which was just trying to
preserve its data when things got more
elaborate was when you took a value you
took some of the data and instead of
just saying I want to take whatever fell
off one end and put it back at the other
end you said I wanted to have TAPS in
the show register where I take elements
at position 7 and 14 and those are the
ones that I I take the exclusive ore of
those of those things add the mod 2 if
they're ones and zeros and have that be
the thing that I put at the beginning of
the shift register to be the thing that
gets fed back so that's the kind of idea
of a linear feedback shift register it
turns out that some math that comes from
um uh theory of finite Fields gives you
information about what will be the
maximal length linear feedback shift
register sequences that's what soul
Golem worked out in the 1950s
um and uh that turns out to be what's
used
a quadrillion times or something or
maybe maybe it's more than that maybe
it's close to an octillion actually
times I worked out that algorithm has is
the most used algorithm in um uh in
history I think
um that um
is used for uh for this thing about
transmitting data in such a way that you
never have just pure zeros you always
have things that have these these uh
these variations and the variations have
these features about being sort of
maximally distinguished from each other
being able to know where in the sequence
you are and so on so that's a that's at
least a very well used algorithm
um the uh there are algorithms that are
also well used in arithmetic and
arithmetic logic units there are some
somewhat non-trivial algorithms that uh
don't do kind of school book things like
Edition where you're just adding and
doing carries it it somewhat optimizes
how many times you use the data for
example for multiplication you would
naively think but sort of standard
schoolbook method method of doing
multiplication of numbers within digits
each is every digit has to be sort of uh
compared with every other every digit it
in the other number and you would take N
squared operations to do that but in
fact it's possible to rearrange that
computation so that you don't have to do
all those all those kind of combinations
and in fact one knows one can get n log
log log or something n number of steps
to do multiplication although the
constant in front is quite big but there
are tricks for getting a little bit
close to that which get used in pretty
much every every arithmetic logic unit
every CPU that's built so again those
are things which have been used many
many times
in terms of sort of algorithms in
general
there are several different categories
of algorithm I mean there are sort of
iterative algorithms where you're doing
something you keep on doing it until for
example something no longer changes like
the euclidean algorithm for working out
gcds that is sort of described in Euclid
um is an algorithm of that type where
you keep on subtracting numbers and so
on and until until you get down to there
being nothing left and as you watch the
progress of what you had to subtract and
so on that gives you the the the the
divisors of a number that's an algorithm
which um was probably one of the
earliest described algorithms from
basically described in Euclid
um and that's again has some
significance although it's not an
algorithm that is necessarily used that
often I mean it's used gazillion times a
day but it's not it's not used the same
kind of at the same kind of high
frequency that's something like learning
feedback shift registered sequence
algorithm is used but one General class
of algorithms are the iterative
algorithms where you either just do
things a certain number of times where
you do things until things no longer
change that do things a certain number
of times versus do things until things
no longer change the the first sort of
do things uh a certain number of times
that's reminiscent of what people call
primitive recursion back in the
beginning of the 1900s when people are
trying to describe well what are the
possible operations that you can do that
make up something like a mathematical
function and they had the idea of
primitive recursion but you just
basically say do this operation uh
actually I should should say that a bit
differently I mean that that's it's
something where you can essentially have
loops but you know how many times you're
going to have to do the loop General
recursion which actually girdle uh
introduced for for his girdle's theorem
work is something where you kind of keep
going until some Criterion is valid and
and that's something which exists even
in the in in something like uh the
euclidean algorithm
um although it wasn't sort of pulled out
in that form but it's like keep going
until something until some Criterion is
satisfied another huge class of
algorithms are the kind of divide and
conquer truly recursive algorithms where
you take a thing and you break it down
and you consider sort of uh sub cases of
that and you build it back up again
famous example of that is the quick sort
algorithm due to Tony on the 1950s
I guess which was an early computer
implemented algorithm again it has this
feature that if you want to sort a list
you might think that you have to compare
every element with every other and see
whether they're in order or not and that
would take N squared operations but
quick sort manages to do that same kind
of sorting in analog n operations by
essentially sharing the work in certain
ways so there's a whole class of
algorithms that are essentially these
divide and conquer break the problem up
into subcases do the sub cases and then
bring it back again also lots of
algorithms that are kind of pathfinding
algorithms where it's like there is a
way to get from here to there there is a
way to uh
um sort of arrange these tiles so that
you can
put them in the plane there is a way to
find a series of moves that you can make
that get you from one configuration to
another those kinds of algorithms and
there were
um uh the Dykstra album The a-star
algorithm these were invented I think in
the 1950s or 1960s
um that are algorithms for doing this
kind of pathfinding and they get used a
lot
um for lots of practical purposes
um I suppose other algorithms that are
famous are things like the linear
algebra linear programming algorithms
like the Simplex algorithms invented by
in the 1940s I guess
for taking a collection of inequalities
and saying what will be the place where
these inequalities are are all satisfied
or what will be the place where where
this quantity is maximized subject to
these inequalities that was the thing
that came out of operations research
that was developed for Logistics in
World War II of saying if you can if
there are these constraints between the
things that can be produced by factories
or whatever else and you're trying to
optimize this particular function where
is the optimum and it turned out that
the answer is that you can describe all
of those linear inequalities for example
as kind of planes that slice or
hyperplanes that slice space and it
turns out the answer is always in the
corner somewhere and you have to kind of
figure out which corner it is and it
turns out that there's a very systematic
algorithm for doing it it's an algorithm
which turns out to again it's an
exponential algorithm in general
um and it then turned out in the took
until the 1980s for people to find
sub-exponential algorithms for that
um and uh and nowadays that you can
solve problems that aren't just linear
slicing problems that are arbitrary
convex functions and that's a whole
class of algorithms where a whole class
of problems that have become sort of
amenable to to study because more
efficient algorithms are found there so
I suppose one thing to say about
algorithms is occasionally there are
sort of methods found that let you
somehow uh take
a particular thing like pathfinding or
like linear programming and suddenly
make it more efficient and then it
becomes the case that you go from a
situation where you couldn't really use
oh now you have to do it in a
programming or oh now you have to do
pathfinding in the middle of some other
problem to the point where that
algorithm has sort of cracked that and
allowed you to be able to do it another
big place where that's happened is
things to do with neural Nets where it
was oh we want to recognize is this a
cat or a dog in this image that used to
be really hard and now it's really easy
um and so that's another place where
kind of the algorithms that um these are
sort of in the case of neural Nets what
tends to happen is you know you train a
neural net and now it will at least
approximately Implement some particular
algorithm the question of the the neural
net training algorithm itself the back
propagation algorithm for example
um that's certainly been a an algorithm
that's been used that's been applied
many times you know in a typical neural
net training these days it's trillions
through quadrillions of those kinds of
operations that are being done you could
say that's an important algorithm
because it's kind of being used a lot in
that case my guess is that's actually
not the ultimate sort of end point of
having on that training should be done
but that's the way that it's done right
now
um and that algorithm again uses again
another sort of important algorithm in
history which is kind of the steepest
descent uh kind of algorithm where
you've got some you know you've got some
function you're trying to find its
minimum and you continually try to
follow the the downward direction as
found by calculus by working out the
slopes
um the downward direction to get to the
minimum you might not get to the global
minimum that way but you'll get to some
minimum that type of algorithm again
very early in history Newton uh I think
really did describe that what's now
called Newton's algorithm for finding
for example roots of equations or square
roots or whatever else where you're
successively iterating to get closer and
closer to the root
um that's again a general method that's
been used pretty often
let's see
uh
um
I uh
okay cat asks here historically who has
led the trends in science practitioners
or academics
well it's varied with a kind of science
it's varied with what you mean by a
trend I mean the general course of the
history of science tends to be
there is some new methodology invented
that methodology might be a conceptual
methodology or it might be an
instrumentation methodology but once
that's been invented there are then lots
of things that can be done with it and
usually over a fairly short period of
time five ten years something like that
there's sort of lots of low-hanging
fruit that gets picked I mean one saw
that early on with the telescope early
on with the microscope your telescope
sort of launched astronomy in a bunch of
areas of physics microscope launch Versa
is a biology
um I suppose in those days that the time
scale wasn't as short as that but in
more modern times you know once one has
kind of I don't know uh you know x-rays
come on the scene there are a bunch of
obvious things to do with x-rays once
some methodology with uh
um
uh some Physics methodology about I
don't know working out uh Quantum field
Theory with asymptotic freedom or
something comes on the scene and what
was sort of a set of things to be done
there once gauge theories come on the
scene in physics there's a set of things
to be done there it tends to be
methodological advance
period of sort of Highly intense period
of kind of um picking low-hanging fruit
followed by a long cruise period that
lasts 50 or 100 years where there's
incremental progress before there's some
sort of breakout new thing that happens
and depending on what the area is that
incremental progress may be incredibly
important in technological and other
applications or it may be something of
primarily quotes academic interest
um that is really being done for the
sake of being done so to speak
um it's not a bad thing necessarily
rather than being done for some known
external application so now the question
is if you look at those periods of rapid
growth who does them
well in the case of ones that are driven
by instrumentation
um that can be done I mean I'm I'm
trying to think in in uh in modern times
um I think about gpus as a thing that
have driven sort of a bunch of machine
learning a methodology and uh you know
gpus were very stop much built by
practitioners so to speak
um for purposes that weren't specific to
um
the use case I mean you know telescopes
were built by you know originally by
sort of lens grinding practitioners so
to speak and the use case that Galileo
put telescopes to of you know look at
Jupiter and find its moons look at the
uh you know look at Venus find its
phases things like this
um these uh this was a kind of a use
case that Galileo found of something
where the core technology had been built
by essentially practitioners I mean
Galileo improved the telescope but the
basic idea of grinding lenses and making
a telescope
um came from from practitioners of that
of that area
um although those practitioners aren't
necessarily the people who make the
scientific advance I mean I've seen that
a bunch of times with with tools that um
uh
that um uh you know I've had the
opportunity to use where I'll give you
an example automated theorem proving is
something that has been long studied
there are many practitioners who who
kind of do that but if you ask what are
the things that have been discovered by
automated theorem proving that one
didn't already know as opposed to things
where you've kind of filled in sort of
yes we can automate it automatically
prove this thing
um just as we could have done it by hand
well I think the only example still to
date of a surprising result discovered
by automated theorem proving was the
thing that I discovered in the year 2000
about finding the minimal Axiom system
for Boolean algebra which I found by
using automated film improving tools
that have been sort of built by
practitioners but they were not the ones
who were thinking about kind of the
basic science of what can be done from
this I think we're seeing the same thing
again with math formalization tools
where people have spent a lot of effort
building these and yes you can formalize
as proofs that have sort of already been
there and maybe it's somewhat helpful as
a way to organize kind of thinking about
these proofs but if you ask what are the
sort of big leaps of science that you
can make using this methodology you know
I've had the opportunity to do empirical
meta mathematics where you ask the
question you know of all these theorems
that people are proving few hundred
thousand theorems what can you say in
the bulk about what the structure of
mathematics is that's something you know
I've been able to do with empirical
matter mathematics building on
essentially practitioner work
um that has where sort of the step that
is the scienceification of that work is
a different step from the building of
the tooling so to speak that will get
done by quotes practitioners so to speak
I mean one had a very early example of
something like this in the Charles
Babbage Ada Lovelace story from the
1840s where you know Charles Babbage was
very much a I'm going to make
mathematical tables I'm going to build
these mechanical computers to do that
and Ada Lovelace you know who themed
herself more of a sort of a poetess of
science so to speak was like well what's
the real overall point of this and then
started realizing things about well
there's this sort of in a sense more
abstract idea of computation and that
was a you know that was not in the let
me figure out you know how the cogs can
be better made for the machine that was
like what's the bigger Point what's the
ultimate in a sense basic science point
there and so there's some division of
labor that can happen in those kinds of
things I think in terms of of um
the question of um uh you know what
counts as a practitioner what counts as
an academic
um you know there's the question of of
uh when people are primarily employed as
academics
um uh you know I would say that first of
all modern Academia is is fairly new
um sort of the the pattern of the kind
of large-scale academic Enterprise with
its very uh structured uh organization
it probably dates well dates from
basically post World War II
um and uh the number of kind of
professional academics before that well
it was a complicated story right because
because Academia was often you know
training for the church training for the
law things like this training for these
sort of intellectual professions so to
speak that was what Academia was about
then sort of science got added to
academic you know mathematics and
science got added to Academia
um and uh
but people who were sort of quotes
academics
often
there was a was a complicated thing of
were you sort of an academic working in
the kind of semi-monastic University or
were you somebody who was at the court
of King so-and-so or queen so and so
um and you were sort of the the court
mathematician or something
um and that was not quite the same thing
as a university setting but in a sense
you were an academic at some level in
the sense that you were you know paid to
just do academic type work or maybe not
maybe you were sort of that segued into
well you were actually paid to do uh
sort of practical work for uh for for
the for that particular court so leibniz
was a good example of that I mean
leibniz
was mostly employed as sort of a not
quite a diplomat but a kind of a back
room Diplomat justifier so to speak I
mean a very common thing that he was
asked to do was to figure out you know
so and so wants to marry so and so but
the conventions of the day were that
could only happen if so and so came from
a a bloodline that was had this
characteristic and that characteristic
okay leibniz go off and figure out go
look at all the all the sort of uh
historical
um uh uh places and show that in fact it
is the case that princess so and so can
marry Prince so and so
um and you know he he did a bunch of
study of that type of thing
um he also was somebody who generally
sort of hung around caught and um uh
I'm sure he was a fairly witty fellow
and people people enjoyed that so to
speak and um and that's how he supported
himself
um so was he an academic was he a what
was he a different kind of you know uh
sort of uh Court philosopher is a
category not so commonly seen in today's
world although although I do feel that
there are occasionally there are there
are people who are operating sort of in
the mode of Court philosophers
um that you see that um even with
philosophers you see that a bit in the
kind of Silicon Valley uh kind of um uh
I don't know what it is um uh not quite
effective altruism but but some of the
some of the things that are kind of
around the sort of um uh philosophy
meets money in um uh
um and and and maybe some of the things
around sort of AI philosophy there you
see sort of that type of of role that I
suppose is the modern version of the
Court philosopher so to speak but I
think in um
um
when you ask the question where do
significant advances come from
um where they don't come from usually is
the vast institutionalized mass of kind
of well-defined work
that's a rare place for for big advances
to come from although there are
exceptions
um and you know usually areas of science
once they get past the sort of rapid
growth phase and they mature lots of
people start doing them they get very
institutionalized there's a professional
Society there are journals there are
conventions there's a whole sort of
collection of of uh of structure which
actually makes it much harder for
something Innovative to happen because
somebody says I'm doing something
different and people say well but if
you're doing it you know if it's really
supposed to be part of this field it's
got to follow these rules and these
rules and these rules are more then it
can't be that different
so sort of almost by definition the the
sort of uh major Innovative stuff does
not come out of kind of the the uh the
heavily institutionalized uh period you
know areas I mean I I think you know
people sometimes say oh gosh you know
there's no innovation anymore look all
these startup companies are all doing
the same kinds of things
well that's because in a sense by the
time you define your Universe of
discourse to be startup companies that
go through venture capital and do this
and do that well you've got yourself to
a situation that's very much like kind
of the normal phase of science where the
the sort of the highly Innovative we
don't really know how this fits together
type thing but there's a sort of big
leap that can happen there has already
happened and you've got to the point
where sort of it's a well-defined
production line and much less sort of
dramatic leaps forward can happen
so I think I mean in in um
uh you know in Academia one of the
things that
is
Academia is is most of Academia is well
optimized in today's world for this kind
of very uh sort of industrialized areas
of of science where there's a big group
of people doing it and most progress is
going to be quite incremental
um the occasionally there will be even
within that area for example uh somebody
who's managed to get themselves in a
sufficiently secure position that they
can like jump out and do something weird
um that ends up making big progress
um unfortunately the the common sort of
sociological point there
is by the time somebody has been Towing
the line for you know a decade and a
half or something to the point where
they you know get tenure and so on at
their University and all that kind of
thing they've been Towing the line so
long that they just like keep Towing the
line
um and it it's uh uh people like myself
who you know I managed to kind of get
through the academic sort of uh system
pretty quickly and I was in a pretty
sort of secure academic kind of role and
I I could do kind of uh things by the
time I was well in my early 20s I was
perfectly perhaps even earlier than that
I was I was perfectly in a position to
kind of do kind of uh uh science that
wasn't quite in the main line of any
existing area and it was okay I could
you know I could make a living even
though I was doing that
um and that uh uh you know that was
important for me at least in terms of
being able able to do things that were
kind of more kind of
different kinds of steps forward than
the the kind of incremental ones that
that tend to be tend to be done in in
most of what happens in Academia you
know I think in uh I think of all these
people I know who've discovered all
kinds of things and uh you know the the
story of almost every major Discovery is
a funky story it's not oh this person
was a main line this that and the other
they were doing what everybody does in
that direction and they just you know
they did a little better and so they got
to this new Point that's almost never
the story
um almost always the story I would say
is uh it was all a bit unusual they were
you know unusually they've been trained
in this area but now they were working
in this area they were trained as
physicists but now they're working in
biology and they're able to sort of
bring one thing to to the other I I
would say maybe you know I'm thinking
about a bunch of different advances that
got made in a bunch of different areas I
mean maybe at least 50 percent come from
these kind of outside of the field you
can think of it as people who have sort
of funky backgrounds versus the more
Mainline kind of uh uh developments of
the field
um
and as I say there's often a division
between these sort of the tool makers
and the users of those tools
um I mean I I myself happen to have sort
of consciously both been in the tool
making world and in the using of the
tools kind of world and that's been
something I've very intentionally done
um of you know I spend a bunch of time
making tools like wolfen language and
then I also spend a bunch of time trying
to use those tools and it turns out
often the things that I discover from
using those tools actually feedback into
the development of new tools and that's
pretty neat when that happens
um but it's it's kind of it it tends to
be more that the specialization of your
tool Builder or you're a
um a a user of those tools to to do
something and and by the way I mean it
it tends to be the case that the kind of
um uh the kind of value system of a
well-developed area like most areas of
Academia tends to be one where it's it's
honed in on oh the the use of the tools
is valuable or the tools are valuable or
something else is valuable and for
example it can be the case that people
are doing something that um where
they're in an area where it's mostly the
write the paper that records the results
and so on and oh you're building tools
and nobody cares about that you can't
you know get tenure building tool tools
and so on which is unfortunate because
that is actually you know some part of
where a lot of the value comes is in
things like the building of tools and
there can be an area where the sort of
the value system is just kind of
excluded those kinds of those kinds of
contributions so that's a another
complicated part of the of that story I
mean there are many many specific
examples one can give
um of where uh you know that many
examples I don't know why I'm thinking
of um
I don't know the discovery of the cosmic
microwave Background by by um
uh uh penzias and and Ono
um in 1964 or so where they're working
at Bell Labs
um I think they had physics backgrounds
I think
um yeah in fact that must be the case
yes
um but they were working on satellite
Communications and they noticed this
background uh radio noise and they knew
about the The Big Bang Theory of the
universe and they sort of were able to
put two and two together and make a
science Advance
um I think uh uh there are
yeah I don't know why I'm thinking of
Carrie Mullis the inventor of PCR
um uh who
I don't exactly know his background as a
kind of a wild character at least when I
knew him
um but uh it's kind of a that was a case
where it was sort of a a more of a
practitioner-driven you know this is a
funky crazy idea and everybody told him
it couldn't possibly work and he was
working for a biotech company and uh
well it turns out it did work and it
turns out it's been very important
um in now is that really you know is
that sort of a science advances that a
tooling Advance it's PCR has been
critical to lots of science advances
um but you know as a as a thing itself
it was more perhaps a tooling Advance
um and uh uh yeah one could go on and on
about about
um these kinds of things where so you
know I think the answer is it's kind of
complicated because of this division of
labor what counts as a practitioner what
counts as an academic
um all those kinds of things but in
terms of of uh you know do the big
advances come out of of the the big
institutionalized areas the answer is
often not because it's much harder to
have a big Advance when you're in a very
structured sort of institutionalized
area
um
um okay there's a question here
uh from Philip asking how did Richard
Feynman view philosophy did you ever
discuss non-physic subjects with with uh
with Hyman absolutely I discussed many
many many non-physic subjects
you know
Feynman always
uh used to kind of disparage philosophy
one of the amusing sort of footnotes his
son Carl went to MIT and made a point of
majoring in philosophy partly because
the old man had had so uh uh kind of um
vocally disparaged philosophy I I ever
really thought that was pretty amusing I
mean at least the Father and Son seem to
both think it was pretty amusing
um
you know I think
dick Feynman always
liked sort of sort of thinking that was
grounded and whenever things started
floating off into the we're just batting
words around and we don't really know
what the words mean he didn't like that
at all because he really you know he was
very keen on I mean his one of his
greatest skills was was calculational
ability and you know he used to do this
thing which which was always amusing
where he would do this big complicated
calculation and he would think oh
everybody can do that which isn't true
at all but then he would go and and
think given that he got the answer he
would say well what's an easy way that I
can derive this without going through
all these complicated calculational
steps and he would come up with this
kind of great intuitive explanation
which wasn't where it originally came
from and then everybody would say oh wow
you know he comes up with these amazing
intuitional explanations his intuition
was good but but um uh and his intuition
about what calculations will work was
very good
um but it was um uh it was somehow for
him because sort of the intuitional part
maybe was a little bit harder than the
calculational part it was like that's
the thing I should show people but also
he really liked the idea that you could
ground any idea in some very concrete
Tower of kind of steps now sometimes
these intuitional kinds of steps they
sound really good at first but then you
realize well wait a minute that step
there how do you justify that step oh
the answer is it's a big calculation but
we don't necessarily see that
calculation and so it kind of it's a
little bit of a mysterious sort of
intuitional kind of thing
but um
I'm trying to think about
um uh
discussions
about
you know
in terms of
of people talking about kind of
professional philosophy kinds of things
I I think he would have been very
disparaging of those things
um and it's like you know and you kind
of make fun of of these things you know
people discussing you know how many
angels hit how many angels fit on the
head of a pin and he'd translate that
into something that philosophers might
discuss about so I don't know
the philosophy of quantum mechanics
things like that
um I mean you know it was some
um now in terms of uh well philosophy of
life that's a whole different story
um I was for some reason I was was um uh
uh you know dick fireman had many kind
of philosophy of life points of view uh
one that I very much ascribed to myself
is uh uh sort of the well he would
characterize it as there are no experts
I would characterize it more as if you
put in the effort you can understand
anything
and uh you know I think he was he was
always very negative and I think it's
maybe the same kind of thing that I was
talking about about kind of grounding
anything you think about in steps you
can understand it was very negative
about the situation where you know the
expert will come in and say the answer
is X
um and just trust me I'm an expert you
know the answer is X he really uh I
think as I say my my version of it will
be more you know if you put in the
effort
um you can uh kind of um
you can understand the steps
I have to say I'm trying to remember
when Dick Feynman was was was Ill with
his well he he got uh
um was got cancer several times and I
remember talking to him the first time
he had that
um and he was he was telling me that um
the surgeon who was working uh on his
case was writing a paper about his case
and I think he he was like um
um uh he was kind of um
um he was slightly amused but slightly
you know is that really what you want is
to have somebody think your case is so
interesting they're going to write a
paper about it
um but I I'm I'm um
I'm trying to remember what um uh
because I certainly talk to him about
those yeah yeah I did talk to him about
that I remember talking to him about in
the case of the in that medical kind of
case about sort of the first principles
understanding of what's going on which
he actually wasn't so much into in that
particular case which was unusual for
him and I think um I'm trying to
remember I remember I'm remembering one
particular conversation must have been
1981 perhaps nineteen
82 I don't know of that around that time
um in which uh
uh uh was some
which was kind of a a common understand
from its principles this kind of medical
thing that was uh was relevant to him
but but um I mean in terms of of other
kind of um
um
uh you know he had
a in terms of sort of Life philosophy I
think he had this kind of he had a
certain self-image about what he was
good at what he wasn't good at
which I don't think was always correct I
think he was sometimes good at things he
didn't think he was good at and um uh
and that uh you know for example one of
the things he he always used to claim
was that uh you know anything
administered anything that involves sort
of people and getting things to happen
and so on he's like he's not good at
that and then that was entirely true I
mean uh you know long before I knew him
when he was working on the Manhattan
Project he was in charge of the human
calculators of the Manhattan Project and
uh no doubt he was um maybe he was more
of a leader than a and a strict sort of
manager in that area
um but that I think seemed to seem to
have gone well but I think later on he
was not somebody you know there were
sometimes academics scientists who build
up kind of large groups around them of
people working with them he never really
did that
um he was always kind of a solo
operative with uh occasional
collaborators who were I would say more
social collaborators than they were sort
of strictly scientific collaborators or
sometimes sometimes uh collaborators who
would uh you know do tool type things of
running programs or writing programs or
whatever else but I would say more the
Criterion for for firemen of
collaborators was I would say probably
more more sort of Social and scientific
and and not the kind of thing where he
wanted to build up a big group and he
had to manage the group and so on he
didn't want that at all
um and he always used to tell me that um
uh my sort of interests in in managing
things and organizing stuff and so on
it's like you don't want to do that
that's horrible that's a that's a
terrible um I think he never really
crossed over the the realization that
there's you know when you can work with
a group of people
um you can achieve more than you can on
your own I mean there is always a cost
to working with people because you spend
a bunch of your effort you know do doing
management and Leadership and so on but
there's also if you you know in the end
there's a lot of Leverage to be gained
there I don't think he ever really
really got that he certainly would
always tell me that it was uh that I was
wasting my time in doing these kind of
organizational types of things I mean I
think that um for some reason I was
thinking about something that he would
commonly say which was
um uh uh Peace of Mind as a prerequisite
to creative work and he always he took
the point of view that that it was
important to sort of cut yourself off
enough from the world that you just
didn't have to worry about practical you
know dealing with this or that thing
which would cause at least for him uh
you know some amount of stress and that
sort of disconnecting from those kinds
of things was crucial to being able to
do creative work that that was something
he would say I I didn't always you know
I didn't really uh the time particularly
I didn't really agree with that
um it didn't that didn't that didn't
really uh but I think it also depends on
what aspects of things uh cause you sort
of to not you know cause you stress that
distracts you from from thinking
creatively and so on you know I think
the other thing he he would always say
talking we were talking about academics
a little while ago you know I have to
say that he he had a definite tendency
for being interested in the unusual folk
and you know he just wasn't very
interested in the whole uh well it's
part of the mainline thing and it's part
of the um uh the kind of um
um
uh you know we're we're going to put
another another step in this in this
long chain so to speak
um he and he tended to like hanging out
with kind of the unusual folk the
artists the uh sometimes business people
sometimes
um uh the people uh you know with um
um with different kinds of points of
view
um I think he always he always liked
that
um and he was found that I think
stimulating
um and uh
um it was um uh and so for for other
academics it was like um uh you know
that that almost didn't compute because
there tends to be a uh you know
academics do tend to uh you know feel
most comfortable and hang out most uh
with academics at conferences or
whatever else and I'm I'm um well I
could tell you a zillion different
um
different stories here about Dick
Feynman I'm not sure
um that um
um I'm not sure how long to go on about
that but um any case
um
let's see there's a question here
about from Baker asking if simulation
becomes sufficiently good will it make
experimental scientists be out of a job
well if we know the fundamental Theory
of physics
and we can work up from that and get to
everything in physics then yes the
experimental scientist would be out of a
job because we've reduced physics to a
branch of mathematics so to speak but
there's a big catch which is this
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that just knowing the
underlying rules doesn't immediately let
you jump ahead and say so this is how
things are going to this is how
everything is going to work there's this
kind of irreducible computationally
irreducible series of steps you need to
go through so just knowing what the
structure of the universe is at a scale
of 10 to minus 100 meters or something
then asking so what does that mean for
the biology of the bacteria or something
like that you can't get there from here
there's a computationally irreducible
sort of irreducible barrier from one
part to the other so in a sense the
existence of computational reducibility
I think pretty much tells you that
experimental science is not going to be
outdone because there are places where
you kind of just have to see what the
universe does you can't just go down to
the foundations and say we know what the
foundations are so now let's just build
up by simulation
now I think um
um it's and also whenever you do
simulation that isn't on the Bedrock so
to speak right down at the level of the
atoms of space or whatever else the
really the lowest level structure of the
universe whenever you do that you're
always doing it on the basis of a model
and a model is something which
approximates the universe approximates
the World by capturing some features and
discarding others and so if you say well
on the basis of my model what's going to
happen am I going to be able to uh I
don't know you know is is is this
particular uh kind of
um process with uh electrons and this
that and the other is it going to work
this way well actually electron's a bad
example because you're drilling fairly
far down there but let's say you've got
some biological thing are you going to
be able to tell that oh I don't know
this electromagnetic wave doesn't affect
biological tissue because gosh we can
calculate on the basis of a model that
this thing will produce this force on
this piece of some molecule and this and
that and the other and therefore we know
the answer
well the problem is you might have
missed something there might be some
effect you didn't know and the only way
you can find that out is to do the
experiment
so by the time by the time things are
turning more into engineering practice
and you're asked well let's take the
following example let's take um uh
airplanes and let's take the case of do
you use a wind tunnel as the Wright
brothers and others did to figure out
what's the flow of air over this wing
and how do I maximize lift minimize drag
whatever else how does that work well
there was a time when the only thing you
could do was use a wind tunnel
um and just see but then computational
fluid dynamics got better to the point
where it was possible to test many kinds
of designs using computational fluid
dynamics I think in modern times you
know the sort of machine learning that
lets you interpolate between the results
of of computational fluid dynamics and
experiments and so on and you can say
well you know if I add this little blob
to the wing is it going to what kind of
effect is it going to have well you can
figure it out by simulation but if you
now start saying well okay actually I
want to study the you know space plane
that's going to you know enter the
atmosphere at Mark 20 or something like
this and then you say well let me just
do a simulation of that good luck you
know a lot of that there isn't a uh
there isn't a sort of the model isn't
well enough set up to be absolutely the
model of ordinary fluid dynamics won't
get you there but you know there are
things that are sort of beyond the
simple model and even just doing the
computation of the model is really hard
in that case but so I think it is it is
true that once things are developed to
the point where you really sort of have
them under control they're part of
engineering practice then you can
probably often just do simulation
because you know the model is good
enough that's going to cover the things
you need for this kind of engineering
practice you can just do simulation in
the case where things have not been
reduced to that no you have to do the
experiment because what about the effect
you didn't think of
so I think I think experimental
scientists won't be out of a job I think
what is true is that there is a
transformation of experimental science
as a result of of sensor data and the
idea you know back in the day it's like
we do an experiment and we measure one
number and that's what our experiment is
about in today's world it's like let's
actually measure you know we we're
getting a gigabyte a second of data from
this experiment and it's a kind of a
gusher of data and both in terms of the
getting of the data with sensors and
they well what do we do with that data
you know how do we deal with it can we
can we just extract one number and say
this is the answer or are we somehow
looking at this data more in the
Aggregate and so on and I think there's
still a lot to be done in understanding
sort of how you develop something Beyond
statistics and Beyond machine learning
as such
um that really deals with sort of the
the big big amounts of data and how you
sort of compare theories with experiment
and so on when you dealing with that I
think you know statistics was all about
you know its original idea it was sort
of understanding the properties of a
state like a state in a government kind
of State in terms of a certain set of
aggregate numbers like what's the
overall population yes we can say
there's this person with that name and
that name and that name that all live in
the city but now we say what's the
aggregate what's the statistics of this
how many people all together are there
here how many people all together died
in this year or whatever else
um and this sort of reduction of the
complete to individual numbers that's
been sort of a story of statistics for a
long time but what we're now getting is
a lot of sort of raw experimental data
and it's less clear what to do with that
and it's it's something where we as
humans uh you know we're continually
confronted with large amounts of data
from our eyes for example and uh you
know we're getting you know megapixels
per second
um and um
uh you know what do we do with this data
well you know we have all these efforts
to you know detect features in the data
in the end the main thing we're going to
do is we're going to make some decision
to do this or do that or we're going to
sort of make a sort of symbolic output
from all of this data and that's um uh
and and you know how one does that in
science as opposed to just we're making
a decision in our life to do this or
that this is um uh this is a different
thing and you know I I think there's
some distance to go in understanding
really how does one make use of sort of
that large amount of sensor data for for
Science and so on
um
let's see
memes is asking how do we go about
solving the goat problem I don't know
what the goat problem is
um could be anything uh I'm sure it's
there's a there's a known thing I don't
know it I'm afraid
um
David is asking
in the history of science what would be
the ratio of number of minor Paradigm
shifts to the number of major Paradigm
shifts
so you know in this model sort of
reminds one of the sort of punctuated
equilibrium theory of biological
evolution that things sort of keep going
in a fairly steady way and then suddenly
there's a big change
I think I think in biological evolution
maybe there are slightly different
explanations for that that have to do
with the fact that uh you know if you're
an organism that is mostly walking on
two legs and then you gradually make
changes to move your central gravity
backwards or whatever else and then
suddenly gosh you can stand up on your
behind legs or whatever and do a bunch
of stuff with your other with your other
legs and then suddenly it's like okay
now we're working on two legs and it
looks like a big change but actually it
was more like an incremental change that
happened to have essentially a different
use case for the same essentially
biological structure I think it's a
little different than than the case of
of sort of Paradigm shifts in science
you know I'm sure it's the case and I
don't know how best to measure this that
there are sort of the big earthquakes
the big changes and then lots of sort of
smaller changes and I'm sure there's a
distribution usually these things end up
being power laws of the kind of the size
of Advance uh uh you know the
distribution of sizes of advances where
there are there are big ones
um that are rare but have a huge effect
and there are smaller ones that are more
common and don't have so much effect and
it's an interesting question whether
there's a way using bibliometrics for
example of looking at citation graphs
and things like this I don't know how
long that that whole world of citation
graph is going to last because I think
that sort of part of the academic system
that's getting fairly gnarly at this
point
um the um
but any case uh you know could you make
a measurement of of this kind of uh uh
you know Paradigm Shift size
distribution I don't know it seems like
a thing where one could at least get
some uh some idea of that
um
uh
okay there's a question here from Brady
asking what was the fifth class of
cellular automata that almost was which
you mentioned in the personal history uh
article that I recently put out
so okay here's the story back in
uh 1983
I was studying cellular automata these
simple programs where you just have
black and white cells for example and
rules that locally say what what color
to make the next cell I was looking at
these things and I was I started seeing
lots of them and I was like what do I do
now I'm doing Natural Science how do I
classify the behavior that I'm seeing
and it was actually rather obvious I
mean a little bit like you know if you
say I've got this material substance and
it's a solid liquid or a gas which is it
you know classify it there might be
Corner cases but basically you can say
it's a solid it's a liquid it's a gas
similarly with cellular automata it was
quite easy to say class one the ones
where everything just dies out class two
it goes to a steady state class three it
continues to produce sort of Randomness
forever and then then there was class
four which was sort of intermediate
where it didn't just uh
become constant it didn't just produce
kind of uniform Randomness instead it
breaks into these localized structures
that have complicated interactions and
that's the place where you as a human
can most obviously get the sense that
it's doing something computationally
sophisticated but I had thought that one
could distinguish cases where uh what
would happen is it breaks into localized
structures where the structures really
are separated
from a case where there is sort of a
background of sort of crisscrossing type
things or something like that a
background of activity where things
don't really separate but they sort of
separate and I thought you could
distinguish those two classes and that
was kind of the class five idea was to
distinguish I'm not quite sure which
order I had the men
um to distinguish the case where you
really are seeing localized structures
that separate from the case where you're
seeing some sort of significant
localized structures but you're also
seeing something that is kind of like a
a Class 2 system but it isn't a pure
Class 2 system where things just go to
constants instead they're kind of are
things continuing to interact in a sort
of simple background way but where the
kind of the the
um the spice of the whole thing comes
from these kind of localized structures
and their interactions so I was kind of
distinguishing between the uh sort of
localized structures with no background
and localized structures with a
background was interacting with them but
as I looked at that more and more I just
found all these kind of corner cases and
all these time scales where things would
look like they had sort of the
crisscross further interaction but you
run them a bit longer and they kind of
simplify out or the other way around
where it looks like it's it's quite
localized but then there are things that
are are more more Global so I I kind of
gave up on that distinction and I think
I think it isn't really a hard sort of
not solid liquid gas type distinction
it's more of a thing where there's a a
range of different possibilities which
one can start to study
um
the question from Universe here has an
idea like the rouliad existed before is
this a novel object
so the rouliad is this thing that I
started describing a year and a half ago
now
um that is this kind of ultimate limit
of all cut possible sort of ultimate
entangled limit of all possible
computational processes
so far as I know it's a really obvious
object to study and it's never been
studied before so far as I know
um the the thing that's tended to happen
is people have had the idea of let's
look for a a computer and see what it
does
let's
um look at possibly something which is
non-deterministic as many possible
computational parts let's look at the
aggregate of what can happen not even
the aggregate whether there exists a
path that does this or that thing but
this idea about looking at all possible
computations and then looking at the
actual computations as they emerge I
think that's just you know I I have I
kind of know the people who are sort of
still living who are in this general
area I think and I think I think
everybody thinks it's kind of a you know
yes we should have studied this I
thought yes we should have studied this
it's an obvious thing to study but I
don't think it was ever really thought
about before I think what has happened
is and this has happened a lot in our
physics project
I've understood slowly
that just uh computation is can be
thought of as cheap in a sense you know
there was a time when people imagined
that these computational steps they're
very expensive there's just one path we
just look at that and so on but the idea
that the universe
can just be an absolute unbelievable
waster of computation the idea that
there can be all these different cases
that are all just running in parallel
and everything's happening and and most
of what we sense is just this
unbelievably tiny slice of all the
things that are happening the idea that
there is computation out there there's
huge amounts of computation going on out
there and it just happens and it's not
expensive so to speak that's an idea
that I think for example for me I've
only it's taken me a long time to sort
of get used to that idea and for example
the notion that there might just be a
tree of all possible kind of um uh
evolutions for the universe and even
just the equivalencing of different sort
of different states of the universe
which are the same state happens only
through the the sort of the the
perception of the Observer so to speak
and that really what's going on is this
unbelievably huge treeing out of
possibilities that that is a reasonable
point of view and not just say how can
you think about that it just involves
too much computation is a fairly it's
something that's only slowly emerged I
think one thing really helped me is in
the 1980s I started thinking about kind
of the physical world as being something
that was could be described
computationally and that really
processes in nature are just
computations the the things we see in
nature are a mere physicalization of
what is ultimately a computational
process and when you start thinking
about computation as the stuff that
happens in nature the idea that there
could be just lots and lots and lots of
it becomes much clearer and so I think
that's kind of the path through which
one gets to that
um
let's see Twister is commenting neural
Nets that
combine seemingly unrelated fields of
research can produce great results they
say but our academic and business
cultures are more focused on
specialization what are my thoughts on
that
well
okay first point
it is the case that there is an
increasing realization that neural Nets
can be generic you can have a neural net
that's useful for language generation
it's useful for protein folding it's
useful for some image processing image
kinds of things there's sort of a
generic finger neural net does I make
two comments about that
uh you could say well gosh golly isn't
it surprising that this one computer can
do all these different kinds of things
but that's the idea of universal
computation that's the idea you can have
that single turing machine that is
universal that can do all these
different kinds of computation so that's
one point that to say we've got the
system that is uh sort of can do all
these different things is is perhaps
less surprising than it might be now
having said that
neural Nets are not Turing machines
neural Nets are one as they're usually
deployed are kind of one One-Shot kinds
of things you just have this big network
of of neurons and so on and you're you
know the the data comes in at the top
and it percolates down and you're
Computing from one neuron to the next
one layer to the next and then you get
an answer at the end
um and that that kind of sort of single
path computation it prevents the
possibility of having arbitrary length
computational steps it really it crushes
out any computational irreducibility now
the fact that there are individual
neural Nets that go across a lot of
different areas my guess is that the
reason that happens is
in many cases is because they're doing
things a bit like what humans do and the
things that we have chosen to identify
as areas we care about whether it's
language generation or image
construction or whatever else are ones
that sort of resonate with the way that
we humans do things and so that's a um
so in a sense it's kind of the one
neural net just like we have the one
brain that is sort of this this thing
that operates in a particular way that's
sort of why we see the sort of the the
same neural net showing up usefully in
different places because those things
are all Are all uh sort of made use of
by the Same by a brain with the same
structure so to speak
now the question of whether sort of the
cross fertilization of different areas
is important to progress in in academic
and business and so on absolutely that's
almost without exception the the really
energetic stuff is happening at the
boundaries between existing areas where
you apply an idea from this area to that
area and so on and you know people have
said I don't know all the time I've been
around at least they talk about
interdisciplinary research and they're
very concerned about how do you take
these silos of research for example and
have something at the boundary I would
say that that that's gone up and down in
popularity I remember when when I was
first involved in doing science sort of
professionally in the late 1970s it was
you know the idea of an
interdisciplinary conference was a wow
this is a new thing this is kind of like
you know the physicists can be at the
same conference as the biologists wow
that's never happened before but the
truth is that in the actual doing of
those those fields a lot of what had
happened was you know physicists had
gone into biology discovered all kinds
of interesting things and so on
um so you know that kind of
cross-fertilization had certainly
happened I think that um
uh that yes the you know the challenge
is
when things get big which includes
science they're hard to organize the
best way to organize things is to
modularize them typically and when you
modularize you create silos and that's
why it's hard to have these things that
sort of go when you have a big operation
going but it's hard to get it to deal
with the things that cross over between
these different areas I mean I know in
um uh even in um
uh in my day job of of uh you know CEO
and a tech company
um you know in fact just today I spent
an hour and a half grinding on um with
all kinds of wild um uh you know
historical analogs grinding on this
issue of we've got these different areas
we're working on this thing and this
thing and this thing and this thing and
now we've got things we need to do which
are new and different never been done
before that involves sort of crossing
over between this era and this area and
it's like but who's going to do that we
have people working in The Silo The Silo
The Silo it's challenging to put those
things together and that's often where
sort of leadership is important is just
defining we are going to have this new
thing it will not emerge from Silo a or
Silo B it's got to be something that um
uh somebody some crazy person has to
come and say we're gonna we're gonna
invent this thing and it's going to take
things from Silo a and Silo B but it
isn't in either of those silos it's a
it's a challenging thing to do even when
you're dealing with a company that has
definite leadership and so on
um to to even like take those ships and
steer them in the right direction is
quite quite difficult
um and it's something that is when when
you're dealing with more of the kind of
what's out there in the world and the
institutional structures that are out
there it's not going to spontaneously
happen let's go to spontaneously the
structures that exist are going to
replicate themselves and the let's make
this bridge this other structure it's
very unlikely to happen and uh so you
know is it the case that um uh that
we'll have sort of systematic ways to
take you know ideas from place a and
place B merge them together make a new
idea in case C uh there are certainly
amusing historical examples there's this
thing uh it's called triz which was a
Soviet era uh Concept in the in very
much the you know the planned economy
plan science kind of Soviet point of
view there was this kind of idea that uh
well we could we can plan everything
let's plan innovation
and so the concept was you kind of take
an idea from one area idea from another
area you kind of cross them over and
that will generate deterministically a
new Innovative idea I don't think it
works particularly well there are you
know there are examples you can give
where it's worked
um but you know in in general that is a
thing that is um uh you know you can you
can imagine you can get a little bit too
structured about structured about how to
make unstructured Innovations you know I
will say that in my own life and times
um knowing a bunch of different areas
and being able to make analogies uh as
well as bring in tools from different
areas has been fairly critical to a lot
of things I've done and certainly with
our physics project and the things that
have emerged from that these sort of
wild analogies between you know uh I
don't know the structure of of
space-time and theories of gravity and
things that you can say in meta
mathematical space about uh kind of the
future of mathematics and so on these
kind of wild analogies
um have have a lot of power when they
when they work out because what will
often happen is that in one area
the the sort of that the branch of the
analogies in that area will have been
well worked out for a hundred years a
lot will be known but once but then in
the other area it's very fresh it hasn't
been worked out but you can now import
the things from the well-developed area
into the less developed area and oh gosh
you can then take the less developed
area and suddenly sort of physicalize it
bring it up to a a level of development
let's say that's comparable to what's
happened in physics for example it's
something I was doing recently with
mathematics physicalization of matter
mathematics of sort of taking ideas from
physics and importing them into the much
less World about the area of matter
mathematics
and I should probably wrap up really
soon here but um I see a question from
rudo here about what would a modern
analog computer look like well first of
all let's talk about analog computers
um the
uh I don't know when the first things
that we would call animal computers
really existed the first sort of
structured I mean we could we could make
up a lot of things as being like analog
computers like slide rules for example
from the 1600s you know slide rules for
those who aren't as ancient as as I am
and used them at one time uh you know
slide rules were used in in until the
early 1970s when calculators kind of
took over but a slide rule is this thing
where you you have this scale It's
usually the logarithmic scale and you
you have the sliding part you have this
cursor that reads between the scales and
you use the fact that if you literally
move a slide
out in some direction and the slide is
marked in logarithmic increments then
when you look at you know the fixed
piece and the slide that was moved out a
certain direction distance you can
multiply numbers just by looking at sort
of how the the uh the the logarithmic
units on the slide sort of add to the
logarithmic units on the on the on the
main part of the slide rule and so on so
you can think about that as a bit of an
analog computer and those existed
certainly from the 1600s and so on
um I would say that the more developed
analog computers oh I don't know um
Kelvin for example in the 1870s 1880s
developed an analog computer for working
out the tides where he would have
essentially It's Like A Clockwork
machine because the tides have these
different components I think he was
doing the 10 components and um uh and
and he's doing something where you're
kind of rotating one wheel and that
makes another wheel go this amount you
add adding up the rotations of all these
wheels to compute the tides I suppose
you could say it's a little bit like the
ptolemaic system in astronomy and
presumably the anticothera device from
around zero A.D
um was is this is this computer that has
has gearing and I suppose one could
think about it it's sort of an analog
computer too where where the analog
where they're gears that can be moved to
any uh the the the wheels can be moved
to any angle it's not digitalized
although it looks a bit digital because
it has you know it has teeth on the
gears that are used to mesh the gears
together and I suppose also are used to
be to have the feature that you know if
you have two gears next to each other
the the ratio of the number of teeth
will be the ratio of the of the rates of
rotation of the different gears but I
think that um
uh that's but I think you know I used
analog computers a few times back in the
day I remember using one at Los Alamos
National Lab back in the beginning of
the 1980s
um and uh in those days so those analog
computers were electronic and they had
um
uh
uh like you know any old
passive electronic circuit uh you know
lrc circuit inductor resistor capacitor
circuit there's a differential equation
associated with that circuit and you
know if you want to solve the equation
for a ball bouncing on a surface or
something like that you can actually
that's a little bit weird because it has
a weird condition to it but let's say
you want to solve I don't know a spring
bouncing up and down you want to solve
that differential equation you can
convert that differential equation to an
equation
um to something where you just have
characteristics an electric circuit then
you can just see what the time behavior
of the electric circuit is and it will
give you what those equations were like
so in a sense what you're doing is
you're saying I've got these
differential equations for example and
I've got this electric circuit which
satisfies a differential equation can I
map the equation that I want to the
equations of the of the electric circuit
now an electric circuit like that is
fundamentally linear in its operation so
that means that if you've got a heavily
non-linear system it's hard to map it to
that linear differential equation that
can be implemented just using
um kind of uh standard electronics and
so on
I think uh
well an interesting question and people
certainly tried this is you know can
neural Nets be made analog I don't think
it actually matters that there are all
those digits of precision in the neural
Nets so it's kind of like well if you
were worrying about making 32-bit
floating Point numbers then yes it might
be worthwhile to have them in analog
circuitry if it turns out it's four bit
numbers it's less important to be an
analog circuitry
um I think uh
people regularly say let's use an analog
computer for this let's use it for some
kind of image processing let's use
something where we're doing Fourier
transforms by doing some diffraction
type thing uh sort of just using physics
I mean by in a sense when you say an
allo computer what you're saying is
we're not going to go through uh trying
hard to make the idealization that data
is represented in bits we're just going
to have the data represented by I don't
know a electromagnetic field
representing some light at this place in
a hologram or something like this
um and not say specifically I want to
bitify the thing
um and then see what happens to those
bits I mean even you know any computer
once taking those bits someone's doing
sort of quotes analog physics to go from
one configuration of bits to another but
you're concentrating on oh and the thing
the state of the system is represented
in terms of bits and analog compute I
think sort of the defining feature is
you never represented in terms of the
state of bits it's just the state of
some system that could include something
you imagine as a continuous variable
um
I think well people you know they're a
photonic Quantum quotes Quantum
Computing companies that are very much
doing uh sort of the optical equivalent
of of um of analog Computing
um so I think that that's kind of what
one would expect the future of these to
be is probably particularly in the
optical domain
um using sort of uh the the properties
of a of a you know a wave front of light
or something like this to represent the
data rather than saying oh it's made up
in terms of these bits and that's kind
of the way one would expect that to go I
mean mostly analog computers didn't
really make it in the probably in the
80s and so on because there was sort of
a huge the programmability of analog
computers very limited I mean when I
remember when the one I was using you
know it had plug boards and you could
connect this to that and no doubt I
think it even had some ability to have
an ordinary digital computer specify
where the uh uh you know where the
switches will be on and off to determine
which part of the system will be being
in use so therefore which analog
function was being run and I suppose one
could imagine a situation where it's
It's All Digital up to the point where
it's specified what the circuit should
be and then it runs an analog but I
think at that point you're getting so
close to just having a pure digital
computer with maybe one additional
component and then you say well I'm
going to read it out digitally anyway so
then why does it matter that there's a
analog piece in the middle that that's I
think the the reason why we're not
seeing so many analog computers in in
the world
all right I should probably wrap up
there so thanks for thanks for joining
me and thanks for lots of interesting
questions and I look forward to doing
this another time
so thanks and bye for now